foreign
[Music]
Holmes one of the most successful con
artists of all time has to report to
prison in a couple of weeks appeal or no
appeal that is the ruling from a federal
judge her lawyers had asked that homes
be allowed to stay out on bail while
they appeal her sentence but the judge
said no she's got to go Holmes and her
co-conspirator Sonny balwani were found
guilty in a scheme that involved a new
blood testing system which promised to
be a breakthrough in health care it
wasn't the company theranos managed to
raise almost one billion dollars from
investors and at one point was valued at
nearly nine billion dollars Holmes was
sentenced to spend 11 years in prison
her legal team claims that there were
issues with her trial which could result
in a new trial once the case makes its
way through the appeals process while
the judge agreed that Holmes is likely
not a Flight Risk nor danger to the
community he said even if she won her
appeal he doubted it would actually
result in a new trial or reversal of all
the counts Holmes who was visibly
pregnant during sentencing last year
recently gave birth as for balwani he
will report to prison one week earlier
than Holmes where he will begin a
13-year prison sentence now Terry you
think the Judge made the wrong decision
why and if so why well yeah I do think
it's the wrong decision here listen
first of all she was convicted and I do
think if you're convicted of fraud in
these types of crimes that you should be
held accountable for what you did but
the basis for not allowing her to be out
pending the appeal clearly and he said
this she's not a danger she's not a
Flight Risk she has an entire family she
just gave birth I mean for all of those
reasons but the reason he said because
he agreed she wasn't a threat he said
because he didn't think she was going to
win the appeal well of course he doesn't
think she's going to win the appeal he
tried the case and so obviously there
weren't any evidentiary issues in his
mind and so I think to decide it based
on that is really not quite fair to to
the defendant because you know obviously
they're going to appeal it has some
Merit she based that Appeal on some of
the evidentiary evidence that went in
there were Witnesses who testified that
the theranos product was not accurate
and she didn't think that that should
get in that's a basis for an appeal and
who knows she could win the appeal well
Brian I mean do you agree and look she
was convicted how often do people not
have to go to prison while their pill is
pending on one hand Jesse I want Terry
to be the judge for every one of my
clients who are ever convicted let's all
get appeals I mean if that is a system
then I love it but unfortunately that is
not the system and the system should not
be different for some over others I feel
from others I feel for newborns I feel I
get it but the judge I think was correct
here to say you have appellate issues I
don't see you winning on these merits so
why should we hold off on your
sentencing while you appeal you should
be treated like everyone else if you win
you get out if not and if seems like you
might not you wait in jail yeah and
these are serious crimes I mean if you
think about it 11 years 13 years that's
uh something that comes into
consideration as well Brian Terry thank
you both so much everyone thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily we
will see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America